does BLM Chicago
stand with terrorists and barbarism or
are they just trying to piss you off or
are they kneeling with them oh good
point all right we'll we'll play I'll
show you the uh tweet that they sent out
which is uh a stand with
Palestine uh this is all that it is I
guess and now it's a black paratrooper
with Palestinian flag flying above the
parachute I think people kind of know
that they flew in to do some
slaughtering so it's it seems and I
don't I I
purposely tried to Shield myself from
the insanity of the beheaded babies and
stuff like that it's like look if you're
seeking that stuff out on the internet
you should also type in good therapist
in my neighborhood while you're Googling
that because uh listen just hearing
about it is is it's damaging
emotionally psychologically enough I
don't need to see images of it but I did
see the images of the GU sort of sailing
in uh to go to the concert where they
got to slaughter all the young and
innocent people and and this is such a
good example of where you can't actually
I I always tried to give people the
benefit of the doubt when I saw a lot of
people seemingly apologizing and
defending of these terrorist attacks you
kind of go look they care about
Palestinians and palestin I really are
living in difficult circumstances and
it's a complicated issue and and maybe
they're expressing empathy to people who
really are struggling and suffering but
this ain't that this is this is people
celebrating mass murder well also it
suggests that your mindset BLM is if
people are being oppressed and PE and
cultures are being destroyed like
Palestine then it's within your rights
to slaughter the oppressor well that's
what BL is saying is going on in this
country to them yeah and they've been
saying it openly this week this is what
decolonization looks like right right
and at the same time they will tell you
that no no the the Arab countries around
Israel they don't want to slaugh they
don't want to kill the Jews no they just
care about Palestine uh well if this is
what decolonization looks like it seems
to me there's a contradiction there and
you know what I thought when I saw this
I'm like yeah maybe maybe they weren't
the good
guys BLM yeah yeah maybe they weren't
the good guys maybe they weren't maybe
they weren't but they've they've helped
so much they've done so much for the
black community some of them have very
large Mansions now so they've helped a
few black people it's been great they
we've they've been taken out of poverty
into a mansion that's the American dream
Adam not to defend
BLM but as a longtime resident of
Southern California when you watch the
news and they go these BLM guys they
bought a mansion for 3.2 million dollar
in toena Canyon I'm like that's 2,200
ft yes there's places in Georgia where
you get a fountain and some ACD with
that not here no that just gets you onto
the property ladder here yes it's a a
ranch house from the 50s with no central
air so again far be it for me to defend
them but let's let's be accurate yeah um
yeah so you wonder back to BLM and many
of these other organizations is the plan
help people or is it just burn it down I
think you know what's very difficult to
do is to build something you know that
Adam it's the hardest thing in the world
to in the world to build something
because you get setbacks you have
challenges the things that happened that
you couldn't have possibly predicted
there were events that happened that
were unfair anybody can tear down a
statue and almost no one can create one
sculpt it absolutely right no less than
one % of people could actually cast a
bronze statue but any drunk
could take it down is basically what
you're saying whenever you're doing
something one of the first things you
experience is your ideas about the world
clash with reality you go oh we just do
this and then you fail and things don't
go the way you intended so you learn you
have to adjust and in order to be
successful in building anything your
view of reality has to be as close to
reality as you possibly can whereas if
you sit on the internet and tweet sh all
day you don't have your views don't have
to have any bearing on reality
whatsoever you can say whatever the hell
you want you can tear everybody down
without having any constructive ideas
about how to move forward that's the big
thing so this is what I was talking
about in my speech that you played
earlier if more people were doing things
in the real world we would have less of
this virtue signaling crap going on well
it's funny I now know how everyone
thinks or what side of any political
subject or even non what shouldn't have
been political like
is by their profession when I meet a guy
who's a carpenter or builds commercial
buildings